US soccer stars Megan Rapinoe and
christen press are gearing up to take
the fight for equal pay to the courtroom
mediation talks between the US Soccer
Federation and the US Women's National
Team broke down yesterday after just one
day back in March the players filed a
lawsuit alleging institutionalized
gender discrimination a spokesperson for
the player said it is clear the
Federation quote fully intend to
continue to compensate women players
less than men they will not succeed US
Soccer did not immediately respond to
requests for comment team co-captain
Megan Rapinoe and Kristen press join us
this morning ladies good morning thank
you for being here thank you gradual
ations yes other thing one day of talks
and they break down that makes me think
there's something very specific at issue
here what is it I mean I think at any
point when they're willing and ready to
come and have a serious talk about equal
pay we're always willing to listen to
what was it that they wouldn't budge on
that made you guys walk out on one day
the issue of equality equality I think
that it's very simple for us and it's
not just about us and it's not just
about this moment we're trying to do
this on behalf of women everywhere to be
treated respectfully and paid lawfully
and the issue is just equality so that
when we play a game that we would be
compensated the exact same that if a man
were to play that game the officials say
that your counsel took in their words an
aggressive and ultimately unproductive
approach how do you respond to that
that's not true that's definitely not
true and we set the posture as the
players in our talks and that that is
not what we came ready and prepared and
willing to have the conversation they
also said that that your approach
followed months of presenting misleading
information yeah I think that there's
some attempt for them to make this you
know he sheds he-said she-said at the
end of the day it's as simple as I laid
it out Megan
the World Cup victory parade you
endorsed president Cordero saying that
you felt he was on the right side of
things you still feel that way in this
moment I don't know I think that there's
a there's a long way to go for us to
feel that way about him about the board
of directors about the Federation as a
whole you know they're the only team
that we that they haven't were you know
there are the only employers that we
have we're tethered together so we're
always going to be open and willing to
listen to that but in this moment no
they didn't they didn't do nearly let go
from here guys do you say you don't we
don't you don't pay us we don't play
where do we what do we do where do you
go there you willing to boycott the
Olympics as the team in 95 began to do
we are very confident that if this needs
to go to litigation that we have a great
case and I think that we will go company
confidently into that because it's based
on a very simple principle that we think
is fair and right and it is the law
there's a court of law question here but
there's also the court of public opinion
and one of the comments made by a men's
coach for a men's team in Atlanta was
that it's ridiculous your effort his
word because the International play for
men is just multiples more popular than
the women's game and therefore equal pay
shouldn't be considered what's your
reaction to that I think we would like
to see US Soccer take a stance of
leadership in this on this issue I think
we have an amazing opportunity to change
something that has systematically
affected women everywhere and it could
be such a positive thing for us to come
together and change outdated and
honestly wrong opinions like that and do
it in an effort of collaboration and
progress I'm curious about your overall
your overwhelming feeling is it anger
frustration do you think what more do we
need to prove I do often wonder what
more we need to do I mean I think it's I
wouldn't say anger but yes it is it is
frustrating it's very frustrating for us
on the team you know for women
everywhere I'm sure
to be feeling like they they aren't
getting paid what they should be we
thank you both for being here thank you
thank you Oh